there's no way out but through for the
democrats and that is they just have to
keep talking if they keep talking they
have to fill the airwaves and they have
to prevent anybody from speaking back
against them okay this is true in the
area of fiscal responsibility is also
true in the area of science
it is just a continuing incredible thing
to me
how the
scientific establishment has been
completely perverted by a desire for
social justice
nonsense it's insane so yesterday there
was a meme that was going around it
wasn't even me it was it was a thing
from health line right health line is a
medical website and here's what health
line is now saying is under parenthood
at pregnancy can men get pregnant
is it possible
yes according to health line it's
possible for men to become pregnant and
give birth to children of their own
in fact it's probably a lot more common
than you might think in order to explain
we'll need to break down some common
misconceptions about how we understand
how we understand the term man
uh so
um no we don't you mean the
misconception that's been held by all of
humanity since the dawn of time because
human
species is a sexually dichotomous
species that is the basis for all human
reproduction
i mean if men can get pregnant i will
say that the birthing process via the
urethra is going to be extraordinarily
painful
you think it's bad through the vaginal
canal try through the urethra
um
no men cannot get pregnant but our
scientific experts are now telling us so
the only way that you can promote
garbage is again to hold an
informational monopoly that is the only
way you can do it
and that's how you end up with this
insane situation with sonic so
there's this insane story that made the
rounds yesterday again this just
demonstrates it demonstrates at full
scale how crazy our society has become
there is a recent viral video of a trans
woman in a heated conversation with a
sonic employee and it sparks a debate
about gender identity and transphobia
here is the video and then sonic said
they would investigate because everyone
is a damned coward here is the video
okay but your entire staff has been
calling me sir
the entire time okay
what about me looks like a sir right now
if they call you a sir i don't know what
they did then because they saw the name
on my credit card and they were being
they were not being nice people well i
mean that's what your name on the card
guy what you want whether one what do
you want them to tell you
that has nothing to do with it
there could be someone in the back that
they don't see
that's paying okay ma'am so why would
they intentionally do that can you tell
me what your location has done to be
transcompetent because clearly they are
not
okay so the entire the entire video is
about a person
who is complaining because this person's
credit card apparently has a male name
on it and people called the person sir
and then this person got angry
so taurus says i demand to be given
respect when it comes to my gender
identity i refuse to let a cisgender
heteronormative world dominate my
existence i and any other trans person
fighting for trans liberation is doing
so to make the world a more inclusive
and equitable world for us as my friend
lola famously said we aren't working
with a broken system we're working with
a system that was never in place for
trans and gender expansive humans i
don't want the sonic manager fired that
would do no good he would be transphobic
the next place he works he deserves the
chance to leave i want all businesses to
hire translate organizations to teach
their employees how to respect all
humans
so sonic immediately looked into this
and
started thinking about whether they
ought to fire this person for the great
crime of pointing out that perhaps the
employees were terming this person sir
because the person's credit card had a
male name on it
it's just it's unbelievable
okay and at one point the employee asked
so what are you can i call you sir or
ma'am
and torah says what would you assume
looking at me and the sonic employee
answers i assume you're a man
and that's when torres turned the camera
to face himself displaying pink lipstick
long hair and cat eye frames and said
thank you whatever and drove away
okay well if you ask somebody whether
they appear to be a man or a woman and
then they give you an honest answer that
is not transphobia if you are a man i'm
sorry it isn't you're a biological man
but again the only way that you can
promote this sort of crap and then you
can do it to corporations
and then you can do it to the entire
society
is by essentially monopolizing the
conversation
i keep focusing on it because it's so
important the monopoly on the
conversation is everything to the left
if they lose the monopoly on
conversation they lose the conversation
they know it we all know it that's
what's behind the facebook crackdown
it's what is behind the corporate woke
pressure
it is all about monopolizing the
conversation and shutting down dissent
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video